hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday November 18th 2019 what's
going on how how's it going everybody
how was your week starting off huh well
you're doing something and having a good
time and just [ __ ] around and then
somebody came in and decided to shut it
down and they never felt more powerful
and there felt more powerful why do you
guys send me [ __ ] to try to [ __ ]
annoy me why do people send me this [ __ ]
they send me this thing where comedian
shuts down show at her own club over
sexist jokes yeah I don't get I don't
even get this whole story that the
comedian was 18 years old and already
owns her own club you know I mean hello
[Laughter]
yeah it's just one of those it's just
it's just what's going on right now I
love also that this happened and it does
it can't just happen you know and it's
not like another audience member went
out and tweeted about this person does
it and then tweets about it you know
does Superman go out and save somebody's
life and just be like yeah you know I
was thinking of hanging in tonight but I
decided to fly around and I saw the
bridge was out on one one side of the
track so I laid down so this train could
get over it out my back's a little sore
but I got to tell you never felt so so
powerful everybody it almost seems as
though the fact that you did it all
right but then you did it and then had
to tell everybody that you did it that
almost seems like you booked all of
those comedians on purpose so you could
do that I mean what you booked these
these shows and you have no idea
what's your booking I don't know I've
never felt so alive sorry I never felt
so alive Jesus I mean just talk about
like I got to be honest with you I've
never enjoyed crowd-pleasing comics I've
never enjoyed them
you know just lingering going for the
applause and all that and this is
literally like the social media version
of this and I also wonder if it was a
bunch of female comics up there trashing
men wired to wire in their set and those
women do exist but they never get in
trouble it's always misogynistic this
misogynist think that I literally had to
look this word up it's called misandry
you know you know that what it's [ __ ]
you could have do I don't know I've
never felt more powerful well I would
feel powerful if I had my own [ __ ]
comedy club at 18 years of age and then
I walked in the room and I go so whoever
that person is congratulations for being
18 years old and having your own club at
least that's the way it's word her own
club I wasn't in her own shower guess it
was her own show but she didn't like
what was going on so everybody had to
[ __ ] go home this is what we need to
be talking about you know sit on my back
porch during the [ __ ] day and somehow
I got eaten alive by mosquitoes and I
looked it up and evidently this is
[ __ ] mosquito from Asia that's called
the ankle biter and they think it came
over in a container or something like
that it [ __ ] it bites you multiple
times I mean you think that this would
be like a priority like hey while it's
the population is still small and it
doesn't need like a giant thing of
standing water they said he could have
like them the size of like a water cap
full of water so I was thinking whoa why
wouldn't we then as
city and a state just go by a bunch of
dragonflies or some [ __ ] that can just
knock this thing out in the most
healthiest way ever you know they'll the
least damaging to the environment or
something like that dragonflies kill
mosquitoes right just know what happens
nope we're just gonna [ __ ] accept it
because there's no [ __ ] money in
stopping those things okay but if
everybody over here starts getting West
Nile virus and babies start having birth
defects just think of all the money that
insurance companies are in our era sorry
uh [ __ ] health care what do you call
those people the pharmacists
pharmaceutical companies will make just
unbelievable but know what that to get
gets no [ __ ] traction nope we should
be freaking the [ __ ] out that that's
going on right now nobody gives a [ __ ]
but a comedian who books the [ __ ]
comics aren't you responsible you're
responsible what kind of terrible job
did you do booking that show if it's
your show you booked it and then you
were so offended by the [ __ ] talent
that you actually had to stop the show
mid [ __ ] show you know and then and
then you go on Twitter and you paint
yourself out as a [ __ ] hero rather
than you [ __ ] the whole thing up if
that's not the comedy you like then
maybe should have done a little more
research I would have been like I've
never felt dumber in my life I booked
the show and Jesus Christ it ended up
being the exact opposite kind of comedy
that I enjoyed and I think I really know
the kind of comedy that everybody should
be listening to so I had to shut it down
you know like when an athlete shuts up
and [ __ ] up I mean and before the the
the media can jump all over him he just
goes you know I take responsibility that
lawsuits on my shoulders you know I've
got to get out there got to do better
you know they do that type of [ __ ] this
is what this person is doing while
painting themself out as a hero tonight
I shut down a string of misogynistic
stand-up comedians as
as in I walked on stage in the middle of
one of them talking address the audience
offered a full run full refund told them
it would not be tolerated here pulled
the show and it's comic from our theatre
immediately lights on go home I've never
felt more alive than right now well if
it's your sheep you booked them I don't
know man
it seems like a big [ __ ] career move
to me who is this brave person I'll tell
you what I went down to the pound and
got a pack of wild dogs and released him
on some children and when they attacked
him I did not like what I saw and I shot
all the dogs I have never felt more
powerful bill how did you know to have
the firearm on you before those dogs
reach those children well as mentioned
before I was the one who purchased the
dogs and released them on the children
do you consider yourself a hero
yes and I've never felt more powerful
20:19 everybody 20:19 you don't do the
research you create the [ __ ] problem
and then you go in and solve the problem
that you knew was coming and then you
paint yourself as a hero and then people
back you up that's so awesome I went
down and I bought some matches and I
licked some newspaper on fire and I said
wait a minute
stop it and I [ __ ] poured water on it
and put it out I've never felt more
powerful oh my god the lives you saved
all right so that's where we're at
well congratulations to her we are at a
place now where comedians are censoring
other comedians that they hired to do
the show evidently unless I'm missing
something in that story which I'm sure
I'm [ __ ] all [ __ ] here something
actually give back it dad
you [ __ ] bald-headed bet headed [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] that that whole
story just makes me sad that this is
what we've become too you know it's and
I want to congratulate all those people
who've wanted to censor comedians what
you've done has worked comedians are now
censoring other comedians and it's now
going to be the kind of show that I
don't know what it's gonna be yeah it
ain't gonna work it's not gonna work
what they're gonna do is they're just
gonna create separate scenes I guess in
comedy you know there's gonna be for
those people that want
I only want jokes about stuff that I can
handle I only want jokes I never want
the comedian to joke about anything that
would hurt my feelings everything else
however is still on the table that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then after that then
they'll go into music and they'll tell
committee it'll tell musicians what
chords they can play to many minor
chords is depressing do minor chords
create depression that leads to suicide
I think it does we had a
singer-songwriter coming to the club and
he's saying three sad songs in a row and
I rang a bell and I said uh-uh
show is over I've never felt more
powerful oh my country tis of thee all
right let's talk football I didn't watch
one down of football this weekend I got
behind in my studies for my instrument
rating here so I was almost ready to tap
out and just be like well maybe I'll
just take it next year I just don't have
the [ __ ] time or I can make a
sacrifice I cannot watch my LSU Tigers
bah bah bah bah give up six hundred
yards in offense
what are you in 58 37 something like
that is that what it was
we've let up like 75 76 points in the
last two weeks I mean I don't know I'll
tell you right now Pete fence wins win
championships so
I'm sure they know what they need to be
working on between now and that game in
January if they're lucky enough to get
there so and then my New England
Patriots beat the Philadelphia Eagles
I like how somebody wrote I saw Twitter
somebody wrote you know every team that
we beat on the way to go into the in
including in the Super Bowl has gotten
their vengeance against us this year
it's like no they didn't he won the
Super Bowl
there's not one Patriots fan that is
excited you know the way the last two
games worked out overall we would have
read we would have rather won the
previous one and lost that one so you're
still doing all right let's say you find
you got the monkey off your back you do
have a trophy and as long as the Jets
don't keep winning it you know you don't
have to worry about getting trashed
about any sort of a drought they [ __ ]
Jets of fifty years in half a century in
and I'll tell you if Massachusetts was
as childish as New Yorkers are we
wouldn't be chanting the year at them
that's my favorite thing right now is
when New Yorkers talk about how
obnoxious Patriots fans are it's like oh
really as opposed to what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the outfield at Yankees
games
those idiots great behavior in the
playoffs this year by the way Yankee
fans absolutely fantastic
there was a coke class class City Boston
class City then they turn around they're
[ __ ] throwing [ __ ] on the goddamn
field let's not forget weren't they the
ones that they threw a knife down from
the upper deck anyways oh and let's get
that let's get to the big [ __ ] thing
in the NFL I did see Thursday night I
did see the replay I got to make sure I
have all the [ __ ] names right and
that Cleveland Brown helmet incident
there I don't think I've ever
seen a more of a [ __ ] like
overreaction I know you're not supposed
to do [ __ ] like that but like I that
whole [ __ ] thing was the hot chick at
the bar starting a [ __ ] fight and
then the [ __ ] hits the fan everyone all
the other combatants are arrested find
in all of that [ __ ] and then she just
gets to walk out of the bar like oh my
god the [ __ ] [ __ ] this place what
the [ __ ] was that
dude mason rudolph was as guilty as
anybody in there and just cuz he got his
big dumb head hit by a [ __ ] helmet
doesn't make him innocent he was a
willing participant a lineman got in the
way of him and that guy on the [ __ ]
Browns he continued to pursue the fight
he was trying to rip the Cleveland Brown
guys [ __ ] helmet off and he got his
own helmet ripped off and then he gets
[ __ ] dinged in the head so lightly
that after it happens he medially turns
around to the referee like shoutout to
that guy in the Steelers who went like
[ __ ] he came in like remember back in
the day the old school wrestling when
the wrestle would come out of the locker
room down thrown a maker's you know he
did that fake kick to the head it was
literally a fake kick he started to kick
and he kind of alligator armed it and
then you know what's hilarious and then
what happens is is all these [ __ ]
people who aren't happy with their own
lives and they don't like that these NFL
players drive [ __ ] killer cars and
[ __ ] top shelf
Johnnie Walker blue [ __ ] are all like
all I can say is that I hope that there
weren't which I knew there were a bunch
of children watching that and looking at
their father and being like daddy is
that what football is what I
saw was the guy in the Cleveland Browns
defending himself from this dis [ __ ]
hot chick you know who's just so used to
you know mason rudolph coming into the
league after all these quarterbacks have
taken all these [ __ ] hits and all of
this [ __ ] and all these [ __ ] rules
have been made so that even when you
have an incomplete pass 90% of the time
it's like [ __ ] pass interference and
you get to drive down the field at the
end of the game like you're [ __ ] John
Elway which you're not and that's not
enough for you now you're gonna sit here
and you're gonna fight what the [ __ ]
what is this guy a linebacker you're
gonna sit there and fight with this
[ __ ] guy how the [ __ ] does he not get
anything it's un-fuckin'-believable Minh
all right yeah he shouldn't have done
that but you know what about his rehab
actually if the guy gets [ __ ] it he
turns around then the ref comes over
like he owns the bar that the [ __ ]
happened in and everybody else gets
[ __ ] over it was a fight dude did you
ever go look at old NFL films because
people that was the most disgusting
display I've ever seen in my history are
watching this game no it wasn't no it
wasn't you guys still remember the
Oakland Raiders in the 70s skip Thomas
Jack Tatum Willie Brown and that other
guy that I can't remember and literally
his move it was almost like he let you
catch the ball you'd catch the ball and
then he would just [ __ ] with his
forearm he would punch you in the side
of the head as hard as he couldn't knock
you out
that was his move he did it to Lynn
Swann just came out clocked him in the
side of the head concussion knocked him
out of the [ __ ] game the guy made a
career doing that and now all the all
these years later disgusting [ __ ]
thing I've ever seen I don't know I
thought that that was that Myles Garrett
is the only in in in the other pic guy
in Pittsburgh
coming to his defense they get a pop
they get suspended and the [ __ ] guy
who was in the middle was 50% of the
reason why that whole thing went down
he's immediately considered the [ __ ]
victim now I know somebody few people
are playing the [ __ ] race card I
think it's just the hot chick in the bar
that's what it is you know you have a
hot chick in your bar a bunch of guys
are gonna come in trying to hit on her
she's gonna shut them all down and
they're all gonna spend a bunch of money
on drinks okay the [ __ ] quarterback
is the hot chick at the bar
nobody gets protected more than him the
wide receivers are like a good-looking
cousin but it's pretty much all about
the quarterbacks in the [ __ ] league
you know having said that I don't know
he is sort of the prototypical [ __ ]
white guy you know full head of brown
head hair with the square jaw I don't
know maybe there is something to it who
the [ __ ] am I to say and I'm gonna stop
this right now before an 18 year old
comedian comes in and shuts down my
podcast and never feels more powerful
yeah you can't have that they find the
right people but I don't know I'd say
like a [ __ ] I would have gone maybe
two games two game suspension he's not
gonna do that again
you know his emotions got the better of
him but the [ __ ] hot chick there kept
ramping him up the only thing that was
missing in that little domestic violence
thing looking there is when the refs
came in to break it up what's-his-face
the hell's his name Mason Rudolph should
have jumped on the cops back being like
that's my boy all right I didn't think
it was that big a deal I don't think
it's as big a deal as ridiculous [ __ ]
disease-riddled [ __ ] mosquitos coming
in from Asia global warming 90% of the
species of fish being fished out of
[ __ ] the ocean you know those stories
pale in comparison
to a comedy show that's not going in the
direction you want to go in and football
players behaving too violently in this
violent [ __ ] game that was the most
disgusting display you know not not not
the results of of playing football and
guys committing suicide that right there
was the ugliest thing you've ever seen
in this game all right okay well you
know what let's agree to disagree how
about that how about that
here comes Pat all right what do we got
here
what else the [ __ ] did I want to talk
about here now wait a minute where the
[ __ ] is oh here it is
you know I'll tell you it doesn't take
it doesn't take much to [ __ ] me up
I watched the end of the Formula One
race I had my kid all weekend my wife
had family in town
I'll tell her tell her her new
expression is not white now maybe
tomorrow she says that about everything
hey you want to try to go potty
not right now maybe tomorrow no thank
you
maybe tomorrow and one of her aunt's got
her little doc mcstuffins outfit so she
takes the stethoscope every five seconds
listens to your heart and then I taught
her to put it on on your back and
breathe in and breathe out and then she
goes you're healthy we probably did that
40 times yesterday I don't know I had an
awesome time hanging out with her and
when she was napping I was studying and
I didn't watch any goddamn football but
I did catch the end of that f1 race
another great this was a really I
thought I thought was a really enjoyable
season a Formula One and I shout out to
Ferrari you know as much as I rooted for
them and they've had bad strategic pit
stops and everything I will tell you
this then unlike Mercedes if they get
wheel to wheel they don't give a [ __ ]
and they race
and as much as they took each other out
and they both got it did not finish
yesterday it was exciting as hell
watching those two guys go at it like
they weren't on the same [ __ ] team I
wish every team would do that
I know for Cindy I used to do it it was
tremendous knocking each other other
erase all the [ __ ] time it was like
you watched the beginning of Days of
Thunder congratulations to Pierre gastly
on his first podium and shout out to
Lewis Hamilton throne and up to messin
up there and knocking that other fellow
there out of the race and another
championship to him and also the MotoGP
is over for the year I've been studying
I missed the last three races but I've
been keeping up on them and everything I
got them all what's great you can just
go to their website and watch them when
I get on the other side of this test I'm
definitely gonna watch him and speaking
of racing I went out and I saw Ford
verse Ferrari last night I went out I
was like you know what I am so far I
haven't seen the Joker I haven't seen
kill the Irishman I didn't see that
other movie that begins with a pee I
think it's called parasite and I went
out I saw I [ __ ] loved it I loved it
and not to mention there has got to be
like [ __ ] a hundred million dollars
worth of cars in this movie if the cars
were real you know Christian Bale as
always was [ __ ] amazing Matt Damon
plays Carroll Shelby when the manliest
men ever with the most effeminate name
Carol that quintessential
white woman name I don't want to ruin
any of the movie but uh Christian it's
just [ __ ] everything every [ __ ]
movie these guys in every [ __ ] movie
the guy said he's just a jerk he just he
crushes it how old is that guy I've also
forgot where he's from
oh he isn't an English actor because I
was like he is crushing this [ __ ]
English accent
so definitely I definitely recommend
that one I went to look a review of it
and some douche wrote this is like a
classic dad movie and bla bla bla bla
bla and he talks about how you know Ford
and Ferrari getting this absolutely
ridiculous competition like I am so sick
of [ __ ] beta males like if there's
anything like [ __ ] manly it like tote
it's so affects them that they just have
to like just I don't know what it is
they have to like it's just I don't know
[ __ ] about cars alright but I can sit
there and watch a bunch of guys that are
geniuses with it and listen to this guy
drive a car around the track and know
what is wrong with the car by the way
its handling I wish I was that manly but
I mean I'm not gonna like then just say
that it's ridiculous
it was incredibly considered us inferior
they considered our car designs vulgar
and they were more refined in all of
that type of stuff it's the classic
underdog story I don't know how you
can't get combined just get behind it
just because you don't know how to
change the [ __ ] oil on a goddamn car
you take it over to Jiffy Lube
which I do too I even do that on my old
truck the only reason why it do is
because the way it was designed the way
the frame is one giant piece goes from
one side to the other side of the frame
on my f100 and it's right under the oil
pan right where it would drain out and
the oil would go all over the place so I
mean ice I know how to do it I still
have my old oil filter wrench that used
to be my favorite [ __ ] thing you know
doing like regular maintenance went back
in the day when I had my first day and a
baby pickup truck at an 83 Ford Ranger
fire engine red just like my pubes and I
I used to die used to do everything on
that thing and including changing the
fuel filter which I [ __ ] up one time I
got inpatient it was cold outside and
snapping the line I snapped it off and
then I was like [ __ ] so I had to have my
truck towed over and I told the mechanic
down there what I had done I literally
left the fuel filter on the seat there
was some sort of miscommunication this
guy went to start it up and they had a
fire and it was hilarious the guy called
me up yelling at me
be like yeah we just had a [ __ ] fire
it's like dude I told you I snapped it
up you said you twist it it's like they
said I snapped I said I snapped it up
you said you drink it yeah I'm so
[ __ ] sick of you [ __ ] guys you
[ __ ] weekend warriors you start the
[ __ ] job you [ __ ] up and then you
bring it down and all this [ __ ]
scream and I had brought this goddamn
truck over to this guy for eight [ __ ]
years and if this guy had just said to
me amen
I [ __ ] up but it was a
miscommunication I would have paid for
[ __ ] half of it you know but instead
he starts [ __ ] screaming he yell at
me then he tried to pull his [ __ ]
where he tried to not charge me for it
and my dad gave me the heads-up go and
you make sure you paid for it down there
cuz if he doesn't charge you there won't
be a record that the truck was in that
shop so I said no I'll pay for it he
kind of gave me this look and bla bla
bla bla bla and I told the thing away
and I ended up [ __ ] going out and I
just on my own pocket I put a brand new
[ __ ] engine in it but we never fixed
the electrical what's hilarious was I
drove that new engine that other guy
tried to [ __ ] me over was a patient of
my dad's and what I learned in that one
has never trust him a mechanic with with
a manicure
which is what he had and ghost white
[ __ ] teeth and wore Cologne and I
remember he said we also need to rebuild
the carburetor I said I think the
carburetor is fine
he put the engine in and he had the
thing running so [ __ ] rich I almost
had to like pull over for gas like every
eight miles so I brought it to a shop
and the guy goes no and he just turned a
couple screws on the side of the
carburetor I should have called that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] up I never did I
wasn't into confrontation as you can
tell from this story people keep
victimizing me and I just keep paying
forth
that's so and then I never I never got
the electrical finished and then I ended
up having a fire the [ __ ] thing
burned down so that happened but I'll
tell you I remember I was in the reason
why I put a new engine in it rather than
buying a new car was I was planning on
moving to New York and I didn't want to
take on all this debt so I would rather
you know back then it cost me about
fifteen hundred two grand or something
like that for the whole [ __ ] thing
underrated keeping your car and putting
a new powertrain in it you know and then
what's great is you have like this I
mean I didn't put the whole they're
getting have a new transmission but if I
went like front to back brand-new
underneath you know you it's essentially
you got a restomod going on right except
you left everything regular and then all
I had to pay off was 1500 bucks
rather than like the cheapest car way
back then was probably like nine grand
or something like that like a Toyota
Tercel or something which was a great
car as far as like if you were a
comedian you drive that thing to the end
end of the ends of the world I remember
where I almost bought one cuz my buddy
Bob Miley comedian out of Maine he
bought one he almost talked me into get
one and then I was like now you know
what I was gonna put the engine in I
remember this woman at work was just
like don't you buying a new car I said
you know I decide to put a new engine in
my old truck instead and she just kind
of made this weird face he was like that
was stupid and she was beautiful
you know like Mason Rudolph I was like
maybe I'm it maybe I'm at fault so
anyway that's what I did I don't know
I'm talking all this [ __ ] car [ __ ] but
definitely go go see Ford versus Ferrari
don't listen to these [ __ ] beta males
talking about this [ __ ] or just I
don't know people who are just sick of
[ __ ] guys going out doing [ __ ] even
if they actually did it and it's party
history it's a [ __ ] incredible story
and I
I also recommend there's a book called
the limit I brought this up a couple of
times and it's about the first American
that won the f1 championship and once
again they thought that we were inferior
you know loud obnoxious Cowboys which
you know was kidding I mean we kind of
are so it's an incredible race but you
also learned stuff about Enzo Ferrari
like how [ __ ] just I don't know when
it all costs that guy was like when the
cars would once one of his drivers would
die his he'd say that he would speed
like oh my god that's terrible and then
his next question would be his how's the
car so I don't know if they kind of
conveyed that in the in the movie but I
will tell you he just speaks Italian and
it sounds amazing what a what a [ __ ]
language anyway
alright let's read some of the
advertising here so bill gives a Ford
verse Ferrari to freckled thumbs up all
right
[ __ ] great movie alright untuck it
the holidays the holidays are almost
here dooby-dooby-doo
and you know what that means gifts
ignoring the mosquitoes with the West
Nile virus you know continuing to eat
fish get a flat screen on every [ __ ]
wall in your house you need gifts and
what better gift to give the guy in your
life than a stylish shirt that fits just
right
unlike most brands untied shirts are
actually designed to be worn untucked
you got to love that untucked shirt
untucked shirts always fall at just the
right length no matter this his size so
he looks casual and schapp ever seen an
untucked button-down they look they look
bad they do it's way too long why
because they weren't meant to be worn
that way thankfully there's untuck it
the original button-down shirt actually
designed to be worn untucked
no matter your size or shape on Tucket
shirts always fall at the perfect
untucked length
with the holidays near there's no better
gift for your favorite guy who needs an
upgrade talk about your frustration with
shirt shopping in the past whether
buying for you or as a gift oh what's
the name of that [ __ ] company Oh
theory theory I went over to theory and
I got a theory those shirts cannot
handle travel
I even got like their sweater I got it
like [ __ ] dry-cleaned and immediately
just started it's all pillowy around the
damn neck I've only worn it like three
[ __ ] times that's my first my
frustration with clothes is not how they
look is can they handle the [ __ ]
grind of being on the road theory can't
j.crew can't I'll tell you what's
alright though is [ __ ] Brookes
brother and you know who else untuck it
goddammit [ __ ] advertise another [ __ ]
in the middle there every time with more
than 50 plus fit combination untuck it
shirts look great on tall short slim and
athletic guys of all ages why can't you
say fat I guess you can't write with
untuck it shirts your shirts will never
look baggy bulgy too long or too big
again and their website is easy to use
they even have a whole page devoted to
helping you find your fit so whether
you're shopping for the perfect holiday
gift are just trying to craft a smart
relaxed style of your own untuck it is
the way to go visit untuk accom and use
the code bur for 20% off at checkout
that's un tu c ki t-dot-com promo code
bur for 20% off all right hims this
Black Friday secured the best deal of
all a healthier thicker hair line that
would be amazing
why do you guys turn to weird solutions
or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science thanks to science
baldness can be optional
hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with licensed
physicians and fda-approved products to
help treat their hair loss no state no
snake oil pills or gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science hymns was created by a
guy who knows some men's health
conversations are easier online than
in-person we should do it in person if
you do it online it's good everybody's
gonna know right everybody reads your
emails don't they no more awkward
in-person doctor visits or long pharmacy
lines for hims connects you to real
doctors online which could save you
hours completely confidential indiscreet
answer a few quick questions a doctor
will review and if determined it's right
for you can prescribe you medicine to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door I'm gonna sneeze no sorry
this Thanksgiving when your relatives
say healthy and full they'll finally be
talking about your hair and not the
turkey healthy and full I don't think
they would say that about a turkey I
think they'd say that about your
pregnant wife it's good it's good to be
a little bigger
that's good means you're gonna have a
healthy baby
try hymns by today by starting out with
a free online visit Cody Hammonds
dot-com / bird that's fo r hims com / /
for hymns com / / prescription products
are subject to doctor approval and
require an online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see website
for full details and safety information
this could cost hundreds if you went in
person to doctor's office / pharmacy
remember that's for hims com / / hang on
alright I'm back
gotta blow your nose after you sneeze I
mean you can't you can't keep talking
right policy genius all right tis the
season to elect benefits through your
[ __ ] workplace to elect benefits most
people know open enrollment as decision
time for health care coverage I have no
idea what I'm talking about right now so
it's time to deliver it with confidence
but it's also the perfect moment to
really reassess your life insurance
needs to properly provide for their
families most people need ten times the
life insurance coverage that they get
through their jobs which means your
employer life insurance is leaving you
underinsured that's where policy genius
can help this is the easiest way to shop
for life insurance for a life insurance
plan that's not tied to your job in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and red tape
the life insurance you buy through
policy genius stays with you even if you
leave your job and policy genius doesn't
just make it easy to get life insurance
they also can help you find the right
home and auto insurance and disability
insurance too so when you're looking at
your workplace benefits for this month
make sure to double check your life
insurance options then go to policy
genius.com to get quotes and apply in
minutes in minutes policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance you got to do it you know when
you're drinking and smoking yourself to
death there's nothing better than
knowing that you got that [ __ ] life
insurance policy stamps.com everybody
you know you know what people hate more
than anything being bothered with little
daily annoyances you know what you know
when I'm talk this guy knows what I'm
talking about
I like this they wrote this copy like an
80s comedian things like being stuck in
traffic or waiting in line or just
having to do things you don't have to do
well guess what you
can get rid of some of those annoyances
just by using stamps.com you know about
Stan's calmness I know what you guys did
think it this guy looks like Ron Howard
met Ron Howard
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now the holiday season
they're [ __ ] comin up quickly dooby
dooby doo you do get started with
stamps.com today so that you are ready
for the holiday rush you can buy in
print US postage for any letter any
package right now right from your home
or office I got to eat breakfast man I
try to go 12 hours without eating that's
my hollow Hollywood diet okay I had
popcorn and candy at the [ __ ] movie
last night look at sky damn seven-year
old now my stomach is growling at 9 in
the morning but the movie started at
8:45 and I munched on that [ __ ] till at
least 9:15 you can even schedule a
pickup with the mail carrier so you
never have to deal with LA traffic or at
least for going or at least going to the
post office I am you got to the best
part yet with stamps calm you get 5
cents off every first-class stamp and up
to 40% off Priority Mail I mean that
[ __ ] adds up stamps calm is a no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
over 700 thousand small businesses
already use stamp calm right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bird that
stamps comm enter BRR
stamps calm never go to the post office
again all right let's talk drums
everybody I know I've been studying and
I haven't been watching [ __ ] football
I taped a few games I'll get caught up
but I got to tell you I have I have been
playing some drums and one of the great
things about playing an instrument is
you know you kind of swirling around in
the Eddy for a while and then all of a
sudden a couple of things come together
and you're playing goes to another level
and all of a sudden
[ __ ] you couldn't handle you can now
handle at least fake it and I started
playing along to some songs that had
mystified me for years years one of them
being Led Zeppelin the crunch which is
one of the most misunderstood Zeppelin
songs of all time the amount of article
is out there out there talking about
saying that that is a funk song and that
Led Zeppelin was actually had a lot of
funk in them is is not true in any level
[Laughter]
it's an incredibly fun drumbeat to try
and [ __ ] play and keep up with but
there is there is nothing about that
song that is even remotely in in the
category of funk music I would say I
think it was their attempt that was for
white guys from [ __ ] England who
heard James Brown and that's what they
came up with on their first attempt so I
have the audacity to make fun of Led
Zeppelin I think I do I think I do
they're an amazing band absolutely but I
would not call them a funk band on any
[ __ ] level but anyways played to that
then that what's it what's the first
song on Jeff Beck blow-by-blow that's
another one that mystified me and then
there's another song on that album when
the guy starts with like a drum solo and
I was a little like I can figure that
out now the [ __ ] is that song I can't
leave you hanging now right there we go
here we go Jeff back blow-by-blow right
there is it this one you know what I
mean that used to [ __ ] me up for Laura
what the [ __ ] is you know and then their
little stupid drum fill there's one here
too that starts with like a drum solo
that ain't it but goddamn how much fun
is that to play is it this one is it
freeway Jam so I even listen that twice
to figure out what the [ __ ] he was doing
yeah that [ __ ]
I know these are thing you can go on
YouTube and you can [ __ ] look those
songs up and then play it at like [ __ ]
190th the goddamn speed or you can try
to figure it out I highly recommend
trying to figure it out first before you
get the little bits in there to make the
whole thing happen
same thing with like learning guitar you
know when you just have like a song
lesson and the person just shows you how
to play it back when I used to mess
around Katara I used to always like
whenever the guy's hand was on the
guitar he showed me the first chord then
I would turn my back to the video they
just listen to him play and listen to
what he was saying it was still way
easier than trying to figure out
yourself but like you see at least start
to develop your musical ear and then I
started to just try to figure out songs
on my own and if you ever want to become
the person that can figure out [ __ ] on
their own you have to try to figure out
[ __ ] on your own the only way to do it
but I think the temptation nowadays with
all the technology to just get all the
answers for the test speaking of which
you know if if it wouldn't save my life
someday if I could just get all the
answers to the [ __ ] test for this
instrument thing I know some of these
days I would actually consider it but
out this week I am just going to I'm
just doing a chapter a day I'm up to
chapter six this eight chapters I'm
doing six today seven tomorrow and then
eight on Wednesday and then after that
I'm doing two chapters a day every day
until the end of the [ __ ] year and
I'm gonna take this test
and hopefully I'll [ __ ] pass it if I
don't I'll still be I'll still get it
next year
although there'll be a whole new series
of [ __ ] test questions on the test or
whatever but you know I'm a busy fella I
did a bunch of stand-up this uh this
weekend I opened for Aisha alpha at the
dynasty typewriter and she recorded her
album and just I got taste I was blown
away you know I remember the first time
I was recording you know a CD and all of
that it's like nerve-racking and she
showed up totally chill relaxed vibe you
know I did my [ __ ] for like 10 12
minutes up in front of her and then she
just came out first show usually the
first show you tight you like okay great
we got the thing like documented and
then the second show you loose and you
[ __ ] kill it she came out like second
show relaxed crushed it and came
offstage wasn't doing that comic thing
of a Moose's - goober came off she was
like that felt great
I'm psyched you know can't wait to do
the next one and then came out and
knocked out the second one I had even a
better set on the second show very proud
of her and psyched that she's doing this
with all things comedy and I did a
couple of shows Thursday night one down
in LA go on Kyle Dunnigan show and then
I did a set on Josh Adam Meyers show
happy belated birthday to him down at
the Comedy Store and I have all of this
[ __ ] new [ __ ]
this whole new chunk just came out I
cannot wait and down Largo on Thursday
of this week and I will be I'm ready to
go if I actually had a big theatre gig
with a paying audience I would not be
nervous the new hour is ready to go I
got like an hour and 15 an hour and 20
and I'm happy with all of it it's like a
jump off point I cannot [ __ ] wait to
be on the road next year
I'm going everywhere it's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome very very very excited
and I'm also excited to say that today
is what is it uh November 18th
I am one week away from going an entire
year 365 days oh wait no yesterday right
whenever whenever [ __ ] November 24th
would be that's six days away I'm six
days away from going a whole year and my
record is threaded 67 days so I got to
get to like Wednesday a Tuesday
Wednesday of next week or something and
I also wanted to go a whole I've always
wanted to go a whole calendar year
January 1st to December 31st and also an
entire birthday so I think I'm going at
least till June of next year and I hate
to say this to all the drinkers out
there because I love drinking and I
definitely miss it the pros of not
drinking are I too many I don't know how
to begin like just the shape that you
get in the sleep that you get the way
the way you look your face clears up
you're not all bloated underrated
watching other people get drunk oh my
god just feeling that that that moment
in the night you know the energy and the
bars people are starting to get crazier
people start saying dumb [ __ ] you get to
watch the stupid arguments not in a
judging way just being like ah I've done
that I'd done though oh Jesus did that I
did this to you know all of that type of
stuff is just like you know to go an
entire year and never wake up in the
morning thinking
you know and then having to make that
phone call
all right not surprised you didn't pick
up I didn't mean it like that I was
trying to be funny it has been
tremendous so yeah I mean I don't know I
don't know where I'm going with this but
I think I'm I might be done I might be
done and that's no longer sad to me what
I used to be like oh come on man you
know you're never gonna have an ice cold
beer again you're never gonna have a
[ __ ] whiskey it's all starting to fade
and it's pretty cool and you know I
think it's great that my daughter has
never seen me drunk I wouldn't want to
do that so you know god damn it I'm a
dad now I can't do it can't [ __ ] do
it so who knows maybe at some point I'll
just maybe do it on the road I was
thinking if I ever came back I would
just do it on the road like one one
night if I worked every other weekend
one night on that run so there'd be two
days a month 24 days a year I go out and
get shit-faced but I'm just kind of
worried that I'd then that would become
too and then I would be drinking here in
LA and I just and that's just how it
always went then I'd be you know I had
always knock it down and then it'd be
fine and then it would slowly be in
control and it would just get ramped up
and out of control again just like
everything in my life my anger my eating
habits all of that I always get it under
control and it slowly spins out of
control again I don't know who knows so
I don't know you know I'm not I'm
feeling bad that I [ __ ] was talking
about that comedian she's only 18 years
old you know what god bless you you did
what you thought was right and you are
18 so maybe in the future you'll be more
accepting of you know people doing
stand-up in a way that you wouldn't do
stand-up but I do stand by I don't think
it's healthy that stand-up comedians are
gonna now censor what other stand-up
comedians
have to say I mean I've been doing this
for 27 years I would never do that to
another comedian I have seen plenty of
comedians that I don't like what they're
saying I don't agree with what they're
saying but I would never try to prevent
them from doing what it is that they
want to do on stage I don't feel that I
have the authority to ever do that even
if it was my show I wouldn't do it all
right that's my own two cents all right
all right who to support dear Billiam
Wallace I'm a huge sports fan from
Scotland and I've increasingly enjoyed
watching the NFL over the last few years
so that's great I'm wondering what
advice you would give on whether or not
I should pick a team to support and how
to do it I did a random team website
generator thing and it spat out the
Kansas City Chiefs that's a good team to
go to be rooting for should I just go
ahead and go for them I used to date a a
Texas girl so maybe the Texans anyways
keep up the good work and any advice
would be welcome I think you have to
pick a team that's good now if you're if
you're gonna get into a new sport I
don't think you have to pick the top
team because then you kind of pile it on
so Kansas City I think it's the perfect
one you know it's kind of like how when
I got into racing as much as I am German
I should be rooting for Mercedes they're
the top team and I think I can't [ __ ]
root for those guys so I was kind of in
you know Daniel Ricciardo I liked you
know max Verstappen
I do root for Ferrari to be as good as
Mercedes which hasn't happened but you
know you just can't like pile on same
thing with like college football Alabama
has to spend the team since I've really
gotten into it over the last 12 years
and I couldn't just pile on for them so
I just picked a rival of them the
Patriots have been on top forever so the
Kansas City Chiefs seems to me next in
line maybe the Baltimore Ravens as far
as two of the most exciting new young
quarterback
in the AFC I think he I think he did
alright was Kansas City Chiefs and also
you get to root for Andy Reed who's been
so [ __ ] closed he can taste it no pun
intended
he'd be a fun guy to see wooden one he
really would be alright here we go
here's another one for you the worst
father ever from Malaysia I believe they
had a Formula One race that they don't
do anymore they had a really cool track
- all right dear mr. burr I am a big fan
of you and your caustic sense of humor
yesterday I came across this news piece
that I would like to bring to your
attention all right first of all if this
English is your second language I mean I
don't even use the word caustic alright
that's amazing all right this is Paul
this is possibly this is possible the
worst example of parenting I have ever
seen a daughter's obsession with meeting
Andy Lau drove her idiotic father to
sell their house to finance her trip to
Hong Kong to meet the guy she actually
met Andy but the guy didn't engage her
in conversation
he's extremely popular in PRC all right
well I got to look this [ __ ] up I gotta
find out who this guy is all right
what is PRC China
hey all People's Republic of China okay
I'm an idiot all right and who is this
guy Andy Lau is he a pop singer is he a
[ __ ] made Matt guy in the in Andy Lau
who's Andy Lau Andy Lau is a Hong Kong
actor and singer look out Jesus he's
crushing it there's not enough broads
and [ __ ] the People's Republic of
China contained that guy alright good
for him all right so he barely he barely
engaged her in conversation he's an
extremely popular in the People's
Republic of China has bodyguards and
gets like 100 requests to me a day so
the father killed himself after writing
a 12 page 12 page suicide note 12 pages
he probably intended to send everyone a
guilt trip that has lasted until now the
silly [ __ ] how could someone make his
own daughter and our own orphan over
that this is [ __ ] tragic I thought
this may be worth your attention why
hope people don't blame the [ __ ] guy
who's that guys living in a bubble wait
a minute Jesus Christ I'm sitting here I
Pat myself on the [ __ ] back that I
that I took I took fatherhood so
seriously that he quit drinking this guy
he goes to me did the Justin Bieber over
there and the [ __ ] doesn't work out the
way he wants it he qicang kills himself
all right the father jumped into the sea
in 2007 with this suicide intended to
make Andy Lau guilty and force him to
meet his daughter the man's weight in
2007 how old is this [ __ ] story I
don't get it I don't know what's good am
I being trolled here the man's daughter
I can't say that name yang something
rather was a big fan of the Hong Kong
actress singer yang now 41 was so
fixated 41
was so fixated with meeting her idol
that her parents felt compelled to help
her achieve her aim and give her
happiness to pay for a trip to Hong Kong
the dad sold the house but his offer to
sell his kidney to a hospital was
rejected because it was illegal in March
2007 she's you know something a 41 year
old daughter allowing her dad to do this
[ __ ] know what if she's still living at
home this is crazy she's got these
people wrapped around her finger she
took a Wi-Fi with him but was devastated
that she'd not get to talk to him well
yeah I would think there's no snow
satisfying this person her teacher
father teachers don't even make money
over their upset over what he perceived
as Lau's indifference towards MS yang
took his life after pending a 12-page
letter yeah and you know how eloquently
was that written this guy's a [ __ ]
teacher but there wasn't one spelling
error in there and the letter he pleaded
with allowed to meet his daughter even
if their chat lasted five minutes
November 12 years later yang has told
YouTube channels see you later
that she has gotten over her obsession
with Lao and is full of remorse over her
deaths okay this is this is all just
reads see you later I think I don't
think this story's true
I don't think that story's true alright
took me to [ __ ] 20 minutes I don't
believe it what is this website that I'm
looking at right now
the Starcom that sounds like a [ __ ]
ray I don't believe it all right advice
sir Billa the red crotch yes you may
enter hi I'm going through a really hard
time with my boyfriend and I'd
appreciate having a male perspective on
this okay
lighten the [ __ ] up don't make him a
sandwich alright I'm having trouble
convincing my boyfriend to have sexual
relations with me oh there's a left turn
are for a while now I've had this
feeling in my gut that something's wrong
I'm always horny but he seems but he
seems to be in the mood last weekend I
found out that he was lying about not
being able to get it up there was porn
all over his phone oh god he might have
watched so much that he can't he can't
perform with the person anymore
which is a thing I grill him okay like
like like you'd as you do and he finally
comes clean and says that he's been
jerking off about two to three times per
week in the bathroom at work what's
worse is that his porn features skinny
broads who are clearly 19 or younger in
some extreme bondage and tortured type
scenarios yeah he took the ride I bet if
you saw what he was jerking off to a
year ago it was probably didn't even
compare to that that's what happens it's
like drinking first it's a couple of
beers Wow man and next thing you know
you're polishing off a bottle of whiskey
in three nights a third a third and a
third porn is the same way you start off
just watching two people [ __ ] you last
for a minute and then you just have to
eat cast to keep going and going and
going and going and going
alright I'm really in doubt as to
whether he's with me because he's
attracted to me or he's only with me
because we have a lot of the same
interests and there's no way
a-five like him can get these nines and
tens that he's been beating his meat to
what okay all right I know I'm a solid
six but I'm not ugly
I have no idea what to think or what to
do my boyfriend and I are in our early
30s I want a man to build a life with
and have a family but damn the only ones
not already marry are either complete
[ __ ] or nerds who don't know how to
[ __ ] do you think you can help me out
here thanks and tell your wife she's
amazing go [ __ ] yourself
anonymous lady I think you're being too
hard on men okay you're in your early
30s you're not in your early 70s okay if
this guy's not doing it for you if you
feel like this is this is a deal breaker
then I say you get out don't hang around
for the holiday gift get out now
if this is something that you feel like
you can work through it all I don't I'm
a little confused on how you view his
porn watching it's just something that
was always not cool in the relationship
or was it okay every once in a while
then he took it too far I don't know but
it was the the main concern is is his
amount of porn watching versus the
attention he's not been giving you has
made you question whether or not he's
attracted to you so I feel your
relationship is at a crossroads and this
is not gonna be as simply hey don't
watch porn oh by the way he's jerking
off at work
are you overbearing the fact the guy
can't [ __ ] find a few moments to jerk
off at home I don't know that's a hard
thing to undo though what he's doing so
he will probably need some help I don't
know yeah you're gonna have to ask
yourself you're gonna want to work
through this with this guy is he willing
to come along do you trust him
if you know if no to all of those then
you might want to cut bait and I would
get a better feeling about yourself and
a better feeling about the men that are
out there that's my advice
oh wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute hey that's me
from somebody else all right
wrong college choice hey Bill Bubba
Zanetti big boy burned baby birth I know
what that means all right big fan of
your work especially hey Bill Bubba
Zanetti big boy burn baby burn big fan
of your work especially the office for
family can't wait for the next season
all right we've been doing punch up on
it it should be out the beginning of
next year hopefully I'm a college
freshman and things are going well so
far
but there are times where I can't help
but feel I made the wrong choice in
college I won't say the college name but
the most I'll say is that it's one of
those Christian schools where religion
is a strong part of the campus life oh
all right he went to doji is you
naturally a ton of people there are high
on Jesus and as such can get on my
nerves a lot granted not everyone is
like this I would think there would be
no happy medium but there are those that
are quite self-righteous and brag about
how many times they go to church Jesus
Christ you pay to go to this school one
particular experience that stick as I
want to start going back to church I
just don't know which one to go to
should I allow my religion to steal all
all of my [ __ ] spirituality that I
don't go to a positive place once a week
I mean it is a good thing to do I
actually think you know to kind of reset
your brain after once a week to be like
hey you know what they're doing things
to others you know the base of the
surface of every religion he's really
cool one particular experience that
sticks with me this one time on a
weekend where I was streamed the first
Jesus Christ people can you proofread
your [ __ ] here one particular experience
that sticks with me was on one weekend i
i streamed the first Ghostbusters movie
this is my roommates first time watching
it and when we get to the end where the
main villains appears he suddenly tells
me to skip past this part to the end
with a sudden urgency I didn't know what
the deal was but he kept on urging me to
so I read reluctantly comply
later on asked him what the deal was he
said that the movie was mocking the
faith and that it was satanic this is
without a doubt one of the most stupid
things I've ever heard I was raised
Christian but I'm starting to ask myself
whether I still want to be I'm not sure
my college choice is really helping
matters and I don't want to drop out as
my parents have really helped me out and
getting here any advice well why can't
you transfer just transfer I just say
listen I want to get a college degree
but I can't even watch ghostbusters
because my roommate is saying it's
satanic okay I don't mind being
Christian but like this is like too
Christian if you know what I mean this
is the thing there's nothing wrong with
any of these faiths there's nothing
wrong with any of them as far as what
they're the surface messages which is to
be a good person and be good to other
people there's nothing wrong with any of
that the deeper you go into it is yeah
that's where it's there's nothing wrong
with having a beer you know there's
nothing wrong with the occasionally
engaging in certain behaviors but when
you do it all the [ __ ] time and go to
and too deep that's when it becomes up
for everything in moderation so maybe
this is too extreme so I would say just
you can still get your college degree
you don't have to go there just transfer
like Joe 10 and oh baby and that's what
I would do that would be my advice I
would say that you should you should
transfer can't you do that
I'm already have to transfer to another
Jesus school or else they don't take the
credits quitting my job
alright quitting my job
hey yo Billy Beach Bob Beach bought yo
Billy beach bod alright writing here
from the Old Republic of Republic of
France love your work big fan of yours
how would you say that shame oh uh that
tribe a a some I don't know no Tom
Triana I can't [ __ ] I have a dilemma
over here I'm finally quitting my job to
start to work on a project of my own
couldn't be happier I did my current
slash old work in computer wait I did my
current slash old work and my company
but man I just hated a couple of Mike
are these like voice texts I have a
dilemma over here I'm finally quitting
my job to start work on a project of my
own couldn't be happier I did like my
current slash old work and company but
man I just hated a couple of my
colleagues there are these two females
they have made my life miserable freakin
politics and random acts of antagonism
towards me but I never let it get to me
I always minded my own business well now
it's close to the end for me so I'm
wondering should I like give them a
piece of my mind or just take the high
road
and leave without saying nothing my
girlfriend has told me I've got that bug
in me where I can go from zero to dark
in a split second and it's true I've had
terrible things that I thought up to
tell these women but I'm not sure if I
should go through with it or not
what would the 30-year old bill do what
would the 50-year old bill tell the
30-year old bill to do merci beaucoup PS
American music is great mate but that's
a fair vote cheer votre I don't know I
think that means go [ __ ] yourself
I don't know how to say um all right is
he making fun of American music here I
got to click on the link here
he says American music is great let's
see open the link what do we got here
what do we got here we have oh Jesus we
have advertising all right the 30 year
old me would would definitely be
thinking about saying something oh it's
jar of flies is that what it is
sorry come on man
oh that's a great I used to listen to
that my old Ford Ranger the beginning
years of my stand-up career when that
came out yeah and now that's what
innocence is broken
anin uh broke yeah all right I remember
that anyways the 30 year old me would
want to do it just like you but the 50
year old me understands women way more
than the 30 year old me and not only
would I not say it I'd be an absolute
sweetheart and you know if you want to
get them just let them know what you're
gonna go do and you're starting this
thing and you couldn't be happier just
let them know that you're starting a
project of your own and you couldn't be
happier
that's how you get people like that back
if you lose your [ __ ] you say a bunch of
rude [ __ ] to them that that makes women
like that ecstatic that they got you and
what you don't know is that you actually
been frustrating the [ __ ] out of them if
your description of them is true that
you've never given into it okay so go
start your own project and and be happy
that's what I would do if you want to
annoy them just talk about how happy you
are going off to go do your own thing
and wish them all the luck in the world
that's what you want to do alright
overrated underrated people who think
hard work means and I'm telling you
buddy the the happier you you are and
the nicer you are and you know they
might even try a couple of [ __ ]
comments before you leave and just look
at them and smile that's it and it will
[ __ ] drive those two broads to the
point that one of them might even try to
[ __ ] you because they have to have some
sort of something don't and that why
they do that I don't know but don't do
that because you have a girlfriend
alright and that'll be even greater then
shutting it down I have a girlfriend and
I'm happy alright thank you god bless
you see you overrated underrated over
people who think hard work means they
deserve success yes it's part of it but
it's not a guarantee so when someone
works hard and they don't achieve what
they want they blame other people here's
an idea [ __ ] brains maybe working
smarter was the edge you needed you know
I was with everything until you insulted
the people you're trying to get to all
right
the second you call somebody [ __ ] brains
they're not going to listen to your
message nobody deserves success success
is I I don't know it's a mystery you
know sometimes you're working harder
than anybody else but you just not
[ __ ] be or you're just in the wrong
thing you know I actually got my license
to sell health insurance at some point
and I worked my [ __ ] ass off and had
to take the test three goddamn times and
I was working my ass off and I wasn't
successful at it because it wasn't my
calling so I think you know when you
fight you have to find what you're good
at and I will tell you working hard and
not being successful and then
complaining about it is is never a good
look
you know competing with somebody and
losing and then saying that they cheated
is never a good look see every team
that's ever played the [ __ ] Patriots
it seems you know is they look the other
way on all this other [ __ ] [ __ ] that
goes on what the [ __ ] did I see recently
another prime example of [ __ ]
cheating that just it just goes
overlooked because it's you know it's
not the Patriots it's fine it's okay
sorry 100 percent fine no problems no
problems whatsoever yeah it's never a
good look to blame other people and it's
in it and yeah and and to walk around
feeling you deserve success because
you've been doing something for a
certain amount of time is an
astoundingly arrogant thing yeah it's
you got to work your ass off and
hopefully your work and ask your
I saw if it's something that you're
[ __ ] good at and then you also need to
get a little bit lucky which is what
happened to me the whole [ __ ] reason
I'm doing this podcast was dumb [ __ ]
luck that Bobby Kelly told me about him
early on so I had a leg up on some
people and then I've done it every
[ __ ] Monday since I guess that's the
work and hard thing you know dumb luck
so yeah so I agree with it by agree with
everything you said other than telling
people [ __ ] brains although you might be
talking to somebody who maybe just
whines at you all the time at work at
that point you're just venting which I
don't have a problem all right that's
the podcast everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
I will check in on you on Thursday I'll
try to watch that Patriots Eagles game
if I get if I get time very happy to
come away with the victory as the NFC
East has always been a tough one for for
the Patriots all right
I'll talk to you guys later